you've got self de development
depression is something that you talk
about what's that um that's
one of the first stages it's like
essentially let's say you're a normal
person you just kind of all you know
about self-improvement is like oh yeah
like go to the gym but eventually you
find the space online you start finding
the books of self-help and everything
some people seem to get stuck in level
one and i think that a fair amount of
like healthy people seem to breeze past
this stage so the healthy people that i
for example i've spoke to have coached
they'll find out about meditation no
fact whatever and they'll implement it
fairly straightforward exercise i'll
tell them okay yeah start exercising a
few almost every single day they'll do
it no problem there's so many people who
become it's only because of mental
health that they're stuck in stage one
which is that they know what they should
be doing they just can't seem to do it
so for these people for example they
would have had an idea let's say nice
and simple to exercise
and they'll be like oh yeah like you
know today's the day i'm gonna exercise
right you know it feels really relevant
then they'll look back and be like wait
it's been three weeks since i watched
that motivational video and i said i was
going to exercise again they just they
fall straight into the same patterns we
could grab this person take them inside
the gym with us make them do the best
work out of their lives and they're so
hyped and everything like you know
they're making some gains they're not
going to come again for like the next
month and it's this self-improvement
depression because
they are now in the space of hearing
about people like me and even you
yourself who have made progress and
we're talking about you know the
fantastic like stuff that comes from
this and everything and they don't get
to enjoy that they just can't seem to
get consistent in any of the habits they
can't seem to make meditation work for
them they you know it doesn't work and
everything they've tried so many times
and it's a very very depressing and like
scary place to be because you feel quite
vulnerable and like
you're no longer satisfied and oblivious
to your old life of you know video games
and porn and everything but now you know
the dangers of them you've watched the
videos this you know oh like i used to
play video games but now i don't play
video games and look at me everyone i've
got i've got girls now and like some
little guys watching that thinking like
wait but i want girls but like i can't
he can't he kind of snap his league of
legends disc in half as you would see
exactly
are you familiar with plato's allegory
of the cave do you know that story
no okay so uh plato gives this story
about um three men that are chained up
inside of a cave and they're looking at
a wall in the shadows yeah the shadows
on the wall right and then one of them
gets freed he goes out into the world he
suffers pain
he can't see because it's so bright he's
been in the darkness and then eventually
after looking at the reflection of the
world in the water and then finally the
world in its full color he starts to see
that oh wow the previous world that i
thought this was all that existed is
only a mere shadow of what is available
for us and he comes back into the cave
and then he looks at his friends he's
stumbling around he can't see because
he's now in darkness he's back he's
regressed back to the previous version
of himself to try and communicate
between where he is and where the people
that he wants to bring up with him is
and he says to them look guys like this
isn't the real world i promise you out
there there is something better it's
more blissful it's fuller and
they're not happy they said look you
can't even see in here anymore you can't
see inside of the cave this was supposed
to be the place that you knew and he
can't see because he's seen what is true
he comes back he's ostracized by the
people that live at a lower resolution
than him and the argument from plato is
look this is the job of a philosopher
it's to try and peer through it's to see
what the truth is and it's to then try
and tell people who need to be leveled
up from that but there is a pain
associated with that if the if true hell
is when the person that you are meets
the person that you could have been
every time that you get to see the
person that you could be continue to
write rise up and you see that through
youtube videos with people that are
doing things and crushing it and killing
it and instagram and models and dabbler
every time you see that
the ceiling of potential continues to
move away and you need to try and catch
up with it now so you just continue to
feel this chasm between where you are
and where you could be
wow and that's going to be painful
it kind of reminds me of the analogy of
the crabs in a bucket mentality so
that's very common in self-improvement
whether one of the guys in the
friendship group will find
self-improvement start working on
themselves and find that no one else
seems to want to like climb up in the
same way and it's it's it just blows
your mind because you want to go to your
friend and say like boys like i've been
lifting some weight and i finally feel
confident you know we're all nerds and
stuff but like look at me i've got some
biceps and stuff and they'll make fun of
you they're like not like we don't do
that type of stuff you're [ __ ] gay
yeah oh like you're going to the gym
that's gay like
come on man that's the worst thing dude
this is my least favorite thing about
british british culture
my least favorite thing by far like
that tall poppy syndrome
is holding so many young people back
that could be amazing that have got
desires for growth that want to go and
do something different but are terrified
because every time they try to do
something different their immediate
social circle takes the piss out of them
what's that tall puppy syndrome yeah so
you can imagine that you look in a field
and there's a field of poppies and
there's a tall one as you go through
which one are you going to chop down
the most likely one that you're going to
chop down is the tall puppy it's called
tall poppy syndrome i don't know the
full history of it i think it's an
australian term originally but yeah tall
poppy syndrome something sticks out
something grows faster than everything
else that's the one that gets chopped
so which one would you rather be like
amongst the masses and just kind of
seeing the same thing as everyone else
or the one up here who kind of like
lives fast dies young dude that's a good
question that's a genuinely good
question so when at the first ever time
that i saw jordan peterson live someone
said to him the depth of my
consciousness causes me to suffer is it
a blessing or a curse to feel everything
so deeply i'm like this is a really
[ __ ] smart question because a lot of
the people that are in the audience
they've maybe started to step out of
plato's cave they've started to look
around and go look
[ __ ] maybe maybe there is more to life
but by taking that
decision you are inevitably going to
suffer as well
and jordan said basically
you
the only solution would be to regress
back to a lower state of consciousness
right to go into some lower resolution
version of the world and a lot of people
escape from their insights with drugs
with alcohol with sex with extreme
sports sometimes people even take their
own lives in an effort to try and get
away from this because they don't feel
like they can find a solution and he
said look it's too bloody late to
regress back
what you need to do is take more of the
thing that poisons you until you turn it
into a tonic that girdles the world
around you he's like you have not less
consciousness but more you go deeper you
go further in and i'm watching this
thing in my head even now man reciting
it the hairs stand up on the back of my
neck i'm like that is so correct you
need to go deeper you need to take more
of the thing that you think is the
challenge
and you turn it into a tonic that
girdles the world around you
um
that's making me think of like the
beginner who starts in the gym and the
first workout just absolutely kills them
they're like oh my gosh you know how do
people do this it's like my muscles are
so sore
and if they stop right now
or even in any sport like kickboxing
rides with if they stop right now every
single time they try to get back into
the gym they'll feel the same pain or
even worse than normal and it's so
interesting that the more you go the
less pain that you'll actually feel
until eventually the pain actually
becomes the pleasure like it's like we
actually like like if my chest doesn't
get sore i'm like oh like i guess i'm a
little bit nervous i didn't even didn't
even hit that [ __ ]
now i'm like oh like oh my god yes boys
like i'm i'm finally feeling chest dogs
whereas before when you get them
our perception of pain
especially in in
positive habits is so so skewed when you
are like when you're currently in
plato's uh cave
because i'm guessing the first character
as he walked outside his eyes is burning
and everything
uh the first thing that he sees he looks
at the world
through the reflection of a lake so he
walks and walks and walks until he hits
a lake and then he doesn't see the world
first
the first thing he actually sees is a
reflection of the world right which is
kind of like the way that shadows work
so he sees a lower resolution of a
higher resolution thing and then
eventually as his eyes finally begin to
adjust he's able to look around and see
the sky in the trees and the birds and
the grass
um so here's a [ __ ] cool story
there's a place in
austin called kuya which is a uh
ketamine psychotherapy
nad iv vitamin iv recovery center that
has sauna and coal bath and you do
what's called contrast therapy so you're
going to a sauna that goes up to 230
degrees and then you get into a cold tub
a single cold tub up to your neck hands
wrists full works and it's just above
freezing it's like three three to six
degrees celsius um and when you're in
the cold tub
it's a very unique kind of pain
because there's nothing to distract
yourself you know when you're doing a
workout the pain is relative to the
effort that you're putting in this is
completely passive pain it's simply
because you're sitting there and it's
short you're only in there for three
minutes three or four minutes right
but if you can sit
and just
think about the sensation that you're
feeling when you sit in the cold water
it stops being pain it stops even being
cold it's no longer cold
it's this bizarre
electric
sort of like it feels like lemon it
feels like all of these things that kind
of
wrap around the sensation that have [ __ ]
all to do with cold electricity and
citrus and [ __ ]
and dude it's the best mindfulness
exercise just sitting in there and
feeling your own compulsion to want to
get out to breathe to feel pain to feel
pleasure it's wild
i was going to say as you were telling
me that story that just sounds like pure
mindfulness training that like as in
cold showers if you try and fight the
pain fight the cold off it's so much
worse but it's so weird that if you
submit yourself to the cold if you allow
it suddenly like it's not as good it's
the same with exercise and everything
that we do the pain
only is
suffering
if you fight it
but if you allow it like that the pain
actually just becomes that pleasure
that's what surrender is that's fully
what surrender is so the first time that
i went i went with my buddy zach big
youtuber uh and we got in and we were
both fine then he got his got in his own
head about being in the cold and a
couple of times he got out early and
then the next time that we went we got
in the cold thing and he's
and i'm thinking you're not going to
last 25 seconds and he got out because
he was in his own head and then
eventually after a couple of more
sessions
he breaks that and then he's back in
nothing's changed his physiology hasn't
changed at all but his relationship to
surrendering to the thing that he's
supposed to do and this is coming back
to what we said before right about
framing what your habits mean to you
you're getting in the cold tub look is
this an opportunity for you to do
something which is going to make you
feel amazing which is a fascinating
experience and a deep dive into your own
motivations inside of your brain for
three minutes that feels like 30
or is it you battling the cold is it you
versus this thing and i better breathe
because if i don't breathe and i'm all
tense
no man
there's a cue that i got from one of the
guys i was training with and he said
what would this be like if it was easier
and it's such a dope cue like what would
this thing that i'm doing be like
if it was easier and it was we were in a
plank and that was when he said it to me
it's like hey man like just remember
like what would this be like if it was
easier and you find yourself actually
easing into the movement and feeling
stronger because you're not tense
everywhere your tense where you need to
be
so it's such a [ __ ] good insight
i really like that i read it in um greg
mcewen's second book effortless
yep yeah i really love that concept
that that comes up in so much like every
habit i can think of right now i've
found that if you think it's going to be
difficult like there's the story you
tell yourself
it's going to be difficult making
youtube videos every day absolutely it's
easy now and
because of that it is easy
because i think it's easy and it's fun
it's going to be easy and fun whereas if
for example before this call
i thought yeah it's gonna be a fun
conversation with chris and that's
exactly what it feels like but if i
could have been tense like oh my god
this guy he's got 200 followers he got
like 200k followers he's got a nice
jawline and everything i'm going to get
anxious
then it would have felt very like
tense and it would just whatever frame
of mind you put yourself in it seems
like the world just reacts in that way
for you
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace